good morning Millennia oh my God what's
wrong I don't know sorry I [__] that
up should we start over no no okay we're
just so authentic we're so authentic but
what was that about actually the other
day this week I found myself kind of
like flubbing GMM also I don't know I
was like just gonna say good morning I
literally I don't know what came out of
my mouth all is that to say like I'm not
okay it's the end of the week you know
I'm malfunctioning
you're not on a high for the end of the
week the latter half
um I am obviously I was Friday I was
thrilled to wake up knowing hearing the
news that it's Friday but you know it's
not Saturday like it's still like a day
at work yeah you know we have everything
ahead of us yeah you know we've made the
argument that Friday's even better than
Saturday because the hope to look
forward to no that's true I don't know
what like what's wrong with me sorry
good morning everyone hey Jax how you
doing I'm darn good I feel like this
week for me at least went by really
quickly and was a really enjoyable
productive week that's fabulous it was a
productive week too I do feel like it
went by really quickly yeah and that's
always good
tis it's like Ferris Bueller once said
life comes at you fast
what's the end of that line you might
miss it yeah classic Ferris classic
Ferris not sure it's the quote for the
day oh you don't think no oh you don't
think it accurately represents what
we're going to talk about here today
what we're the sentiment that we're
sharing which is like it was a good
productive week but life comes at your
past Jax I guess this week came at me
fast that's what Ferris was trying to
say got it thank you for speaking on
behalf of Ferris that's what I do um
we've got a great show today we have our
long-awaited deer toaster segment you
know the week the week just you know got
away from us it was nice to see how much
people were craving it and for people to
miss your toasters and to question where
is your toasters and today's the perfect
day for DT so far it's quiet stories are
light like it's dear toasters day agreed
I've got some great submissions no
updates this week because nobody gave us
any because everyone's doing well right
and it's summer you know we're
approaching summer summer summer we're
approaching summer like people are busy
living you know everyone's doing well
and no update is as much as I love to
hear how people are doing I take it is a
good sign well today's kind of like a
crazy day for me like almost a beginning
of a new Journey
which journey is that let me tell you I
bring my laptop to work every day it is
truly the band of my existence it's so
heavy I like I live pretty close to the
studio but I often take a cab just
because I can't carry this laptop and I
don't know why it took us so long to
think of the idea to get a laptop for
the studio that basically just like
lives here and we got it yesterday and
we set it up yesterday and today is my
first day I walk to work lighter than
air oh my God I might as well have been
floating through the streets like it was
such a quite literal weight lifted off
my back it's crazy that we never thought
of it yeah I feel like we have thought
of it for a while I was the one who used
to bring my computer but I used to bring
a travel air so it wasn't that that
crazy so I'm just if I look like lighter
that's why okay you do look like I feel
this sort of like Angelic weightless
presence I would say that you embody an
Angelic weightless presence thank you
Jackie
thank you Kevin that's enough do you
like my shirt I do Luke Combs merch you
know where I got it Amazon Amazon I was
watching this program Amazon live with
these two sisters who were really so
wonderful they just they really made you
feel like you were a part of their
family that's so sweet and I was
influenced to buy this t-shirt it says
Luke Combs oh also speaking of sisters I
watched our episode um of the toast from
yesterday when I got home I don't always
do it but I felt like yesterday's
episode was worth re-watching okay
um and my God like I did not shut the
[__] up like I was on I felt like I was
on Adderall I I've had like a lot to say
and it had been like about Scandal but
it also just been like a crazy busy day
in general and I was late so I felt like
I had to like take a dump verbally and
my God I did not shut the [__] up like
I'm so sorry that's okay I actually
listened to the episode not watch I
listened to the scannable portion
because Zach was like what'd you guys
have to say about it I was like why
don't you just listen what if you just
put in your headphones and it's like
overall I don't know what we had to say
about it you know like what was that we
didn't have like a takeaway or like a
hot take per se but it was just content
that needed to be broken down broken
down and highlighted certain parts
certain parts I agree with you about
um the Sheena conversation was really
powerful it was yeah he was like nodding
along you should go back and watch old
episodes like when he has free time
abandon yeah he's he's kept up through
the years so when this happened he knew
exactly what was happening okay and
weirdly this season before the news
dropped he was watching the season every
week already like he had caught the
first episode was like oh this season's
good and so we started watching it
together and then when Scandal happened
we were already on the same page of
enjoying the season
and now we've enjoy it that's fabulous
it's bringing people together
it is yeah it really is
um so we've got a great show today
stories are what are the stories tell me
tell me a little bit about their
background I would say they're of the
Friday variety where you know closing
the loop on a few stories some
follow-ups to other things that we
talked about throughout the week and
then just some general randomness
to me those make for the best episodes
yeah I agree completely like there's so
much pressure when there's like a big
story we gotta break down but today's
like a low pressure it's Friday who
cares what we're talking about and I
think that feels great that feels right
that definitely feels right much like a
redhead's rating oh I wanted to update
everyone on a conversation we had a
maybe you know with me was it two weeks
ago it was two to three weeks ago or two
to three months I feel like it was one
week or two to three years I really
don't know what was it when we were
talking about you know our teachers
last week last week I did reconnect with
Ms sheinbein I she heard our cries
she commented on our Instagram and we
had a lengthy conversation I was sending
her pictures of like Harry she was like
asking how the kids were she's like Has
Olivia is that Michaela and Levi um it
was a really good catch up she has like
a ton of kids she's still a teacher she
lives in Israel like it was great that's
so
good so yeah closing the loop so that's
a
the work that we do in discussing our
teachers and it comes with the cons the
inevitable cons about other teachers
hearing things that you said about right
that just make you want to die what did
the toast give it the toast take it the
way yeah but you should share the
positives yeah and you know what
outweigh the negatives we made a new
toaster I guess she hadn't heard of the
toast over in Israel it's fine I'm not
offended my shinbein and she said she's
been listening to it on her commute and
she just loves it what would the toast
in Hebrew be called
means bread not toast
um
warm bread
let's actually look it up what does how
do you say toast in Hebrew oh my God
I mean I like that better oh there is
like a full word
cosit I don't like that
that's beautiful Jackie that's beautiful
oh well I think we should get into
everything I have really not much to
catch up with you anymore
toasters and we've gotta get there we've
gotta get there yeah so further Ado dude
here are the fast side stories that you
need to know
and today's fast five stories that you
need to know are brought to you by State
Farm the State Farm personal price plan
helps you create a plan that gives you
options so you get an affordable price
and it comes with a lot of benefits like
the coverage you want a policy that
helps you cover what's important to you
and of course an affordable price just
for you so what seafarm is basically
trying to say in you know more words
than this is that insurance is personal
some say more personal than comedy some
say more personal than food and some say
more personal than poetry I mean Jax and
I have you ever met more similar garlies
in your life and even we require such
different Insurance Jackie's a homeowner
she has two cars I have nothing to my
name but I still require Insurance
that's just how the world Works
personalization means that you have the
power to choose what you want to include
and what you want to leave out it just
feels better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that too that's what
the State Farm personal price plan is
all about you can choose to include
options like building your home and auto
policies that means you'll get the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you in the end you'll have a
policy that gives you exactly what you
want and doesn't that feel better
hmm
like a good neighbor State Farm is there
wow like a good neighbor State Farm is
there that was the best one yet really
yeah that was the best it ever went call
or go to statefarm.com today to create
your State Farm personal price plan
prices vary by state options selected by
customer availability and eligibility
may vary again you can call or go to
statefarm.com today create your State
Farm personal price plan and stop being
general you know start being personal
today's episode is also brought to you
by manscaped summer's coming and if your
man is ready to unveil his Beach bod
there or if he's not our friends at
manscape are here to ensure that his
body is ready for the wild with their
game-changing grooming and hygiene
products don't have your man be the guy
at the beach with the Austin Powers
chest hair and if he has a little winner
dad bud the least you can do is make
sure he smells nice and is well groomed
it's time to get your man ready for Hot
Boy Summer by going to manscaped.com and
for 20 off plus free shipping use code
toast so manscaped products are really
fabulous they've got you covered year
round but you know we got more Skin
showing we're headed to the beach some
of us are going to Ibiza Ben can't be
wearing his sweater right it's really
hot you know so here's some of the
products that we love for manscaped
especially for the men in our lives they
are dedicated to helping men level up
their full body grooming game with their
performance package 4.0 so that kit
comes with the essential lawnmower 4.0
which is a waterproof cordless body
trimmer and um they also have a ton of
other liquid formulations to round out
the grooming routine so whether he's
trimming his chest the treasure chest
this is the best trimmer on the market
their trimmer features a ceramic blade
designed to cut hair on loose skin and
to reduce grooming accidents thanks to
their Advanced Skin safe technology and
you know what what's so great about
manscapes is like it's so great they're
going to want to be using it all the
time and you're going to be the one like
having to clean up the sink and I think
you know that's a fair trade-off you
know you're getting a gorgeous chest
gorgeous balls and you're also sweeping
up the remnants of what they left behind
and I think that's okay that's really
sweet of you but they've really got
everything they've got nail clippers
tweezers grooming scissors really
everything get 20 off in free shipping
with the code toast at manscape.com
that's 20 off and free shipping with
code toast at manscaped.com
um also Father's Day is coming up it's
also a great gift like it comes with
like a really nice travel case like it
it's like you don't have to wrap it like
it's all in there um having the right
tools for grooming is essential do
yourself and your men a favor by helping
him upgrade his self-care yeah thank you
you're welcome okay
oh story circling back to a top story
from yesterday Harry and Megan's car
chase quote unquote story is kind of
unfurling okay Harry and May first Harry
and Megan are demanding the photo agency
give them footage of the Chase and the
agency is firing back so Prince Harry
and Meghan Markle are trying to put the
squeeze on a photo agency that claim
their freelance Paparazzi who followed
the couple Tuesday night were not as
Megan and Harry claimed highly
aggressive and didn't cause a near
Collision as we stated right they were
upgrade release a statement saying that
they're
people and freelance photographers were
not in any way acting
dangerous seriously maybe nefarious is
subjective is it nefarious to take
someone's picture without them wanting
it you know me so they're saying they
weren't they weren't acting dear
catastrophically right so Harry and
Megan's legal team fired off a letter to
backward photo agency claiming in part
that they need the agency's footage of
the chase to shore up their own security
add in quote we hereby demand that
backward immediately provide us with
copies of all photos videos and or films
taken last night by the freelance
photographers after the couple left
their event and over the next several
hours backwards lawyer has rejected
their demand saying in a letter quote in
America as I'm sure you know property
belongs to the owner of it they're not
in America third parties cannot just
demand it be given to them as perhaps
Kings can do
perhaps you should sit down with your
client and advise them that his English
rules of Royal
prerogative to demand that the citizenry
hand over their property to the crown
were rejected by this country long ago
we stand by our founding fathers wow
okay I mean they took Liberty with that
statement although they're not wrong you
can't just demand and it's not like they
were asking for the footage for like a
legal case they just want it to tighten
up and honestly like it would be nice
for back grid to hand it over so that
Megan and Harry can know what went wrong
but by no means are they required to by
law
at all no it would just be nice like
yeah oh I need this can you help me yeah
sure but like to send a like a
threatening legal letter is probably not
the best way to get what you want no and
like demand there's no requirements
there's and there's no real like reason
for them to demand like have to give it
over to them I also wonder why we
haven't seen the footage since there's
been so much like you know they said
they said and Megan and Harry are saying
the paparazzi were acting in a dangerous
way and and backward is saying like no
we weren't like why not just show us
what happened yeah
I also just think it's a weird tactic
because at the end of the day like Megan
and Harry are asking for something from
back red as like a favor they really are
not legally in any way required to hand
this stuff over so to send like a Stern
letter from a lawyer maybe they felt
like intimidation might be helpful but
this is like a big company and and they
have legal teams of their own I just
don't know if that's the best tactic to
get what you want I also feel like if
there were like a high speed chase in
the city with you know cars driving on
sidewalks pedestrian footage there would
be so much pedestrian footage that's
actually really especially over the
course of two hours but then a New York
police Source said that the the ordeal
from like when they left the city field
Ballroom to when they got home was like
20 minutes oh the report said two hours
they're reported that what we said
yesterday I'm sure it's somewhere in
between yeah also when we were talking
about it yesterday I totally forgot
where Zig field Ballroom was and I just
assumed that they were downtown because
like everything's downtown it's on 54th
and then the precinct that they were 60
or 60 seconds and then they were going a
little more Uptown so like no yeah
there's no room for heist like for a lot
a long right that whole probably from
zigfield to where that no no no no
because 20 blocks is a mile depending on
where they live I'd say maybe like one
and a half to two miles it's really not
enough for a car chase and of course
what knowing what we know about the city
you really can't
physically create a car chase right
without garbage truck running into a
garbage truck a parked car a building a
restaurant on the street like there's
really no way yeah this is the weirdest
story it's a weird story a lot of people
are like poking holes in it and you know
saying that they think that it's been
fabricated and exaggerated and it's a
bad look for the sussexes I also don't
know why they're continuing it like yeah
they really shouldn't have I don't know
why they really want this footage to the
point where they're going to send a
letter and now it's like creating
another wave of news and more people
coming out saying this thing look like
just so entitled like give us your
footage yeah no it's not it's not a good
look and the um the Liberties taken in
this statement are quite funny I'm not
gonna lie in America yeah wow it's
really just giving like Revolutionary
War Vibes you know the versus the
Americans who will win who will win but
what about like they took all this
footage why what are you going to use it
for no and by the way
Harry and I think Doria or maybe one of
their
we're filming security guards like I saw
pictures of Harry like with his phone
sideways like he's filming a patreon
video filming so they have their own
footage yeah also there was a source
that said I don't know which Camp not
Harry Megan's Camp I don't know if it
was like a police Source or someone else
I was saying that actually their
security was acting in a manner that was
more unsafe like they the way that they
were trying to like navigate the
situation was causing more
Calamity well that's definitely a
takeaway for me that whoever's in charge
of security for Harry and Megan like
isn't doing a great job because again
taking them out of an armored vehicle
and putting them in a Yellow Cab is re
in the midst of what they said it was a
high speed chase is such a bad call so
maybe that's why they want the footage
to like see what went wrong but like
they needed a new director of security
operations that's what I'm thinking a
new diso yeah there is a video here of
their cab is that like a Paparazzi
footage or bystander I think Paparazzi
see this is so bad like this is so bad
their windows are complete they're
leaving like they're they've left to
Harry and Megan so vulnerable in an
untinted window imagine just sitting
there there flash bulbs are going off
this is not TMZ that they have this oh
so like they're just sitting ducks in
this Yellow Cab no it's a terrible idea
whoever put them in this car and that's
actually like a security threat like
that I understand them feeling unsafe
like that's such a dumb idea yeah
I wonder what was going through the
driver's mind at this time like he
stopped at a red light or whatever spoke
on it no I know but he's thinking like
I'm gonna be a star you know he's
probably just picks up and drops people
off every day there's probably like a
monotony to it and then one day a
princess gets in his car it's probably
nothing like picking up Keenan it's
probably nothing like and you know who
would never have put them in danger
Keenan super driver yeah Uber drivers
but specifically like the one that I
spoke to who like really I thought
you've had multiple I have but like the
first one like he spoke so highly and
that's why I've been on like alert for
Keenan every time somebody else brings
him up got it
do you feel like I should tell that
story like people know what we're
talking about
I think they know okay also we have a
patreon episode Claudia's favorite
stories yeah where since now like we
cite the stories but we don't go into
them because it's been established so
repetitive she's talked about them a
number of times we have a patreon
episode where we went through a list of
like maybe 20 stories that Claudia likes
to cite and she tells the whole story
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help me God so help her it's a
really good episode patreon.com toast
and also if you head over there you'll
see my Vlogs from the eras tour from my
trip to Dallas for the ACM Awards like
really kind of Premium she's been like
on a vlogging premium filmmaking we're
actually supposed to film a vlog today
yeah I hope that we do that I don't know
if we'll do it directly after this
episode but I'll come I'll come by later
yeah sure it's gonna be really cool I'm
going shopping in Claudia's closet for
maternity clothes and I've like really
needed to clean out my closet anyway so
like I'm really looking forward to
getting some of this crap off my hands
it's a win-win yeah and then we can go
shopping to fill the holes
are you ready for our next
our meeting
um but they've been dating for a long
time and just never either of us realize
okay Miley Cyrus details meeting
boyfriend Max mirando on a date that was
blind for me and not really for him so
she is on the cover of British Vogue and
singer songwriter detail the story of
how she met the fellow musician he is a
drummer in the band Lily and familiar
well it's l-i-i-l-y Lili
Lily I think that's how it's pronounced
she said we got put on a blind date she
was first seen hanging out with him in
November 2021 wow at the Gucci love
parade fashion show in La she said well
it was blind for me and not really for
him I thought the worst that can happen
is I leave the publication noted that
Miley received a call from Max Midway
through their interview her ringtone for
him is Erica Badu's Tyrone on which she
commented I call that boyfriend sexy
ringtone okay one month after the
fashion show the pair were photographed
getting close backstage during her
Miley's New Year's Eve party as they
held hands and dance tonight how do you
miss all of this I don't know and this
is like over a year and then in March
2023 they were at the Versace show
together in L.A which like we just saw
always popping was popping missed that
again it's probably because like not to
be rude he's like a nobody but she's a
major yeah yeah every relationship she's
been in in her whole career we've known
about so true and it's not like she's
been hiding from us no she's been
clearly very uh public literally hears
them in 2021
damn they kind of look like maybe it's
because like if I saw a picture of that
I would have thought it was one of her
siblings because she has so many and
they all have long hair or just like a
friend and the picture itself like isn't
giving relationship love romance it's
kind of just like oh we're both dressed
in Gucci for the show well she wasn't on
my list of singles but like I did think
about her as like a single person so I
just need to readjust my mindset but now
like that they have all this years of
relationship under their Belgium or just
hearing about it now like I'm really
happy for her and I feel like maybe
she'll get married I can appropriately
ship like knowing that this is real
right there's you know they have a track
record it's been a long time history
yeah that's nice you and me
had a whole lot of history
we could be just like when is One
Direction gonna get back together like
this Hiatus starting to think it's not a
hiatus but you don't love Harry solo I
Do I Do by the way but I don't think I
love Harry solo more than ever Than One
Direction More than I ever loved One
Direction and the music is just as good
like One Direction music I'm sorry I
will literally this is like a point I
will take to my death is some of the
best music ever made like the song we
just sang is so good
Midnight
Memories like all their songs are good
songs and I will fight anyone who
disagrees with me and all of Harry's
music is really um who's
[Music]
um
you don't think Harry's music is better
I think they're honestly equally as good
I know that's like crazy to say because
Harry's is more critically acclaimed I
think a lot of people would consider
Harris is like more mature right and
artistic I agree with you they're
equally as good but I think that's a hot
take is it I think One Direction's music
is some of the best music I ever made
and I just and I think actually as we
age it gets better you would think it's
like teeny bopper music you know it's
music we liked when we were six like no
it's [__] good it's not like the most
deep [__] but it's good pop music like
it makes you dance it makes you shake
your ass it it's good yeah
it's more than that though yeah but I'm
saying it's not like the most deep
lyrics
so there it's not surface lyrics or it
is it's a little surface lyric it
depends on the song yeah but then they
tried to go deep with little things and
it's like stop talking about myself
yeah I'm not I'm not going to One
Direction for like introspective lyrics
that will make me rethink you know my
identity but that doesn't that's not the
only thing that makes good music no I
like the beat
you know
so I forget the point I was trying to
make when I was
Miley
you wouldn't either need that history oh
okay yeah yeah
um oh and it's not just a hiatus
yeah but that was like a deep tangent it
happened so quickly yeah it wasn't like
a fluid train of thought that we could
trace back no no not off track we broke
out into a song and just kind of
disrupted the whole thing right but
that's really the story like she doesn't
cover British folk she has a boyfriend
named Max and they see a million
Maximilian that's his full name oh
because his name is Max with two x's
very cool
he's obviously like a purveyor of
language and Linguistics no and like
this is so Miley like he's artsy never
heard of him but he's exists and he's
like in the scene and great yeah and
like I don't really need her to have
like a gangbusters blockbuster
relationship because that that was Liam
and it was really good while we had it
and knowing what we know now is like it
had its problems of course but she went
through that era and she can settle down
with nobody she gave us that you know
she'd give a lot she gave us a lot and
even after like we got a lot of music
years later yes so I don't feel like she
owes us
public relationship a high profile
relationship like we she gave it to us
yeah I mean I am still shipping like
Hannah and Jake but like it's okay but
not Miley and Jesse Cody
no Miley and Jesse the brunette what's
her last boyfriend Cody
oh oh I think I'm sorry I'm talking
about Hannah Montana like the characters
oh yeah no I was who like which Hannah
Montana love interest like were you well
Jay Graham was the one he was but he
cheated on her remember no he
at a party and like Oliver got a picture
on his flip phone it's Hannah
[Music]
she had Jesse and she had the others but
it was he's OTP oh I really felt OTP was
Jesse I mean she wrote smooth talk and
she wrote he could be the one yeah I
guess I meant like he wasn't but I like
if I wasn't pretty close like
considering he was so different from her
I I just now that I never thought about
this before but like the fact that Jake
Ryan like was the one for her like I
actually don't agree I didn't like him
I just feel like he was one I don't know
why no I you're totally entitled to your
opinions who did she end up with I think
you're right Jake but Lily right right
like best friends forever yeah
We Stand Jake no Jesse that was
confusing
not really Jake and Jesse Jake Ryan let
me say Jake Ryan Jake Ryan yeah he's the
first C last day yeah are you ready for
our next story this is more romantic
news because Jeff Bezos has been on his
500 million yacht with his girlfriend
Lauren Sanchez and it appears that there
is a bust of Lauren yeah he had like a
statue created of her on the vessel yeah
um and that's why it's 500 million I
feel like it maybe would have been 400
million without that the bust no I mean
I can't even see a whole picture of the
whole ship yeah there's like a zoomed in
Paparazzi but like here's the ship
there's a helicopter
it's so big and a helipad it's so big
500 million dollars and so there's this
statue and I guess it sort of looks like
his girlfriend Lauren Sanchez
um but is it no I think a lot of people
would consider this odd and edit is but
for me I feel like immense relief
because Jeff Bezos is clearly all in on
Lauren Sanchez like it's been years he
has a bust
and it's like his embarrassing text
messages were leaked all those years ago
and it wasn't for nothing like if
anything seeing this weird you know
Testament of his love in the shape of a
statue made of marble makes it all worth
it you know we read those humiliating
text messages that got leaked to
National Enquirer by her brother I think
and it was humiliating and we and you
know everybody mocked him endlessly and
at least it was for true love yeah
they're going strong they are going
strong and it's nice and it seems like
they have a lot of fun they really enjoy
their circumstances she's
age-appropriate which I think a lot of
you know you know the top 10 most rich
men in the world who end up divorcing
their wives don't always go for the
age-appropriate girl so I think I have
no choice but to stand honestly
okay I'm happy for them she's not the
obvious choice you know yeah it's nice
no I don't I don't not like I don't know
that I I ship on the on the vessel
um because I just don't care enough but
I I do think they're like a solid legit
couple who is very much in love you
don't ship on the vessel but do you
ship the vessel
the boat itself
um like it's kind of
ugly it's kind of ugly and like I just
want to be honest like I really don't
feel like you need to spend 500 million
dollars on a boat you know me I'm like
excess of everything and I want the
nicest boat ever like the nicest boat
ever like the 100 million dollar one
like isn't enough even the 100 million
dollar ones have heli yeah yeah I don't
know why this one is so expensive it
looks like a pontoon by the way yeah and
I think it also has sale
um it's a sailing yacht which is I think
actually unless you don't like it's a
nice feature to have because right if
you run out of gas like it's unnecessary
it's a mobile no like it's it's it's
pretty smart it's like a backup
emergency plan if the vessel fails yeah
you can always just put the sails up and
and get to work and set sail quite
literally quite literally but yeah no
it's a crazy boat and so I just need to
understand like what it has that the
other boats that are so crazy don't have
I just I guess it has her for me like
for me to think that your boat is like a
little too much like and I really
more is more with me I'm not one of
these like eat the rich people like yeah
go I just I think you've crossed a line
when I think this is too much yeah
because like I've seen you know people
go on boats and you know on Instagram
they're like oh my god look this is one
of the and it's like a 200 million
dollar yacht 500 yeah
why
it's not even your house
you use it on vacation what a couple
times a year the 100 million dollar
one's not enough it costs 25 million
dollars a year to run right it can
accommodate 18 guests that's it and
requires a crew of 40 Sailors so I guess
there's like 60 people on the boat okay
and how much like dead ass does it cost
to build a cruise ship
like you know like Carnival how much
yeah like the new ones Celebrity Cruise
they're always killed a cruise ship I
feel like they always announce like
their new feature and they say how much
it costs okay today's newest cruise
ships can easily break a billion dollars
although construction costs can vary
widely depending on the ship's size in
fact almost all cruise ships with a
capacity of over 3 000 passengers cost
over 750 million dollars to build so
he's in like the same budget as a boat
that's carrying 5 000 people 3 000
whatever like that's I'm sorry hold me
crazy I'm eating the rich this is
unnecessary yeah having said that I
would not turn down an invitation on the
boat and maybe get a front row seat to
the bust itself to the bus itself let's
get back to the bus is it her or is it
just a funny coincidence no it's her I
think it's her too because most of these
bus we actually just read a book for the
redheads it was about
um bust making it was about the woman
who inspired all the busts that were
made in like the Gilded Age they're all
over the city like you know MetLife
building like she's um called Angelica
in the book and she's just a perfect
specimen of a woman she all the
sculptors you used her as their like
model fit model exactly
um and this doesn't have that Vibe of
like that Greek she looks like a modern
woman she looks like a modern woman
there are no like statues made of like
unknown people that aren't like giving
physiques like they have curves and
imperfect breasts like they're older
standards of beauty they're older
standards of beauty there's no hair
extensions right or implants yeah
implants yeah no it's totally hard I
think it's a really sweet romantic
gesture yeah that's like a nice gift to
get for your partner when you are that's
what I was a multi-billionaire and they
have everything and like you just need
it to be thoughtful and expensive yeah
and it's like here I had a bust made of
you and I'm putting it on my yacht and
that's how much I love you yeah like
when you're that wealthy you've got to
get creative because there's really only
so many Birkin bags like that can fit in
a closet right so that's a regular
Tuesday that right you get a Birkin bag
right right
comes around every once in a while and
what we know about Jeff from his League
text messages is he's actually quite the
Romantic yes
and he just wants to get drunk with you
a little drunk yeah and read the
newspaper with you exactly and I'm sure
they do a lot of that on the boat I'm
sure that they do the boat is called
koru spell it k-o-r-u it's mayori for
the loop often found on silver necklaces
which symbolizes New Beginnings
I don't like it if you had a boat what
would you call it mine would be called
the turdy Lou the turtle
right guys be at the dock at six Turtle
loose at sail yeah oh 600 hours what
about you
the roldini no oh that's cute
the role is a nice name yeah I feel like
I'm below deck like all the boats have
four letter names yeah Arrow it needs to
be something like Poetic not so
obvious just like a nice
beautiful word
what are words we love
the wench
that's period period the Wench when she
lives the when she's making her maiden
voyage
I gotta be there for the inaugural sale
are you ready for our next story
yeah Dixie demilio was taken to the
hospital in an ambulance after feeling
faint did you say demilio was
hospitalized on Thursday after feeling
faint at work an ambulance was called a
source tells page six and she was
treated at the hospital for dehydration
and is now feeling much better
we're told the 21 year old singer still
planned to make it to the demilio
Footwear launch event which was
scheduled for Thursday evening despite
the medical incident and sure enough she
did show up to the event in an
all-leather look just hours later she
wore a black bandeau top and matching
maxi skirt with her newly Platinum lock
slick back into a ponytail so here she
is at the event looking gorgeous
um after having just been in the
hospital it's giving like Elvis it's
giving overwork yeah let the girl rest
yeah they're so young like I'm sure
she's okay but you don't just like go
call an ambulance and go to the hospital
right any day like and yeah like you
have to be extremely run down right and
I don't really feel like
you know Footwear is like an important
like I feel like she could have skipped
it
I'm sure this was a big launch for them
demilio Footwear it came across my Tick
Tock yesterday the dad made a tick tock
and I looked at the account I'm like
demilio Footwear I must have missed a
chapter but obviously it's like a new
thing it's right now the chapter starts
they're doing a lot they are like as a
family where in the world is Addison Ray
posting to ig a little bit she got
booked for another movie with Ryan
Reynolds I know but like she's so pulled
back I know
I'm just trying to support her me too
and I actually think ultimately it'll be
a good thing for her because like you
know it's a slippery slope to like
overexposure and honestly it feels like
the demilio's like might be headed that
way
um but like I just worry for Addison
I know but I just trust that she's doing
what's best for her I really do okay she
seems okay and every time she like pops
up she's okay yeah
but yeah the demilio's do a lot but I
think it works for them like they must
sell a lot of Hollister and a lot of
shoes yeah a lot of coffees and uh
selfie ring lights like because here we
go another one Addison Footwear
demilio Footwear yeah well wishing Dixie
the best you know take some rest yeah
break is okay a break is okay
please rest please are you ready for our
fifth and final story yeah
Starbucks is changing the type of ice
that they use in drinks and people are
in a tizzy over it why I don't feel
particularly are you talking about shape
shape I don't like crave I think
Starbucks Ice is like a weird shape are
they going cubed they're going nugget
which is better this is huge for the
community it's huge but people are upset
they think it's gonna melt too quickly
that's a fair fair concern honestly like
I have a nugget ice machine I love it I
don't find that it melts really quick
but scientifically like it's smaller I
get it yeah in a statement to people the
coffee giant announced its plan to begin
changing the ice used in its signature
drinks as part of a multi-year rollout
starting this year quote as we continue
to innovate and make investments in the
Starbucks experience for our partners
and customers we are introducing new
machines that make nugget ice to select
stores this year customers who have
tried nugget ice in our handcrafted ice
beverages during testing had a
resoundingly positive response many
stores will not see the change this year
the company is prioritizing stores that
have a high volume of cold drink orders
so I guess like hot locations yeah yeah
no I feel like if they they tested it
extensively I think melting would
obviously be a concern when it comes to
a focus group on ice so I feel like
there was no merit there
that people's concerns are that they're
melting yeah
like I'm sure they looked into it
this is like a like I know it sounds so
stupid what we're talking about like ice
shape but like for Starbucks it's huge
this isn't like produce so much ice and
ice is weirdly extremely personal of
course what's your favorite shape
I'm not a huge ice girl actually I guess
sometimes it can be really dirty I know
yeah also I don't like ice in certain
drinks because it does melt inevitably I
don't want a watery Diet Coke
oh I like a dyke I like ice in my diet
Coke but I don't like ice in like my
sparkling water some people do I think
that's me either because it's like I'm
just mixing sparkling and plastic with
flat yeah like maybe if they made cubes
made of sparkling that's great that's
like also there's like ice talk where
people have all these varieties of ice
well it's really iced coffee icing is
really smart but like
there's not enough time in the day right
but people who actually make ice cubes
out of iced coffee and then use that in
their iced coffee so that like if it
melts throughout the day it's completely
fine is like they're living in the
future of those people they are but they
also have insane amounts of time insane
amounts of time and then people have
different shape dice for like the
different glassware that they have and
that's nuts and then they have um like
color like flowers in their eyes yeah no
they lost me there yeah but like the
coffee thing actually makes sense I
would do like frozen Diet Coke like
that's a good idea Frozen Diet Coke
cubes oh for my diet coke can yeah how
would that does Diet cook freeze yeah
yeah
but
we should try it 100 patreon yeah
yeah
I think I wonder what
compelled them compelled them to change
the eye shape right there's nothing like
special about their eyes but maybe they
want to be special I think a lot of
people like if I am going to get a soda
and there's a Chick-fil-A and a
McDonald's like I actually and I'm just
getting a soda I probably would go to
Chick-fil-A because they have the
crushed ice well they're not crushed
nugget yeah and it just makes the
experience more special it really does
it's so stupid but it does right and I
feel like maybe people would drink the
drinks faster and then get more drinks
and I know a lot of people think this is
gross but there are people who are ice
chewers people like finish a drink and
then finish a cup of ice too they chew
on the ice throughout the the day
um so if you're an ice chewer nugget ice
does elevate that experience they're
doing it for the ice chewers it's
possible it's possible maybe that's not
the whole reason but they definitely
factored in the ice chewers yeah I think
it's exciting change you know I know
that doesn't like it's not like you know
when they put those Lids on the cups
where it's like you're actually that was
destructive you're being harmful that
was destructive to the community I don't
think it would be the worst idea for
them to offer both ice shapes but they
can like they're already people
customize their orders so great easily
like these words is like they need to
just have one ice machine to be you know
the assembly line I think the
personalization of coffee is what draws
so many people to Starbucks like they
have so many different okay ice in there
that you could have it be personal but
people take advantage and they get
carried away and it's not right like
it's it's just a coffee and it's just
Starbucks like I wonder how they do bro
thinks of this because uh she was in the
hexagonal ice
she probably doesn't think it's elevated
enough she probably doesn't go to
Starbucks whether they you know triples
like a barista in her basement 100
percent
cool well this doesn't affect me I don't
get my I don't go to Starbucks me
neither I use the ready to drink I use
the ready to drink I had one this
morning but you know what my ice wasn't
right
my ice machine like makes these huge
cubes I by the way it was sticking out
the top of my cup I just leave it there
thecubes that come from a traditional
refrigerator that are almost like a half
moon shape Half Moon those are the worst
types of ice shapes the refrigerator
companies should be changing their ice
you know a lot of new Samsung
refrigerators make
nugget ice it's like a reason a lot of
people are getting new fridges damn I
mean I got a new fridge recently in
Florida and I didn't even think of that
damn and then there's smelly ice
and then there's smelly ice I remember
like many many years ago this like big
expose in the New York Times came out
about ice like having fecal matter in it
and from here on out like as a family we
never used ice at restaurants anymore
okay sorry there's two separate things
like there's that the fact that ice
weirdly is so dirty and Carrie like
because people stick their hands in it
yeah restaurants and in public places
but like I have a nice freezer yeah I
don't put anything at home is safe I
don't he bit anything crazy in it but my
ice can get smelly and then you have to
clean out the entire freezer I was
Googling it you have to take everything
out you have to wipe down the whole
freezer because it's like the smell of
fruits are good it starts to penetrate
the ice it ruins every drink so I
actually use my ice machine that like
sits up on my counter not in the
refrigerator and that also needs to be
cleaned but it's just a water tank it's
actually not hard to clean it at all
yeah that's better you're living an
elevated experience yeah I mean I did
spend 500 on a nice machine but it was
an anniversary gift that Ben got for me
which is actually like one of the better
gifts I've gotten you and Ben are like
Jeff and Lauren
who's that
Bezos that is so nice my ice machine was
from 500 ice machine 500 million dollar
yacht get you a couple who could do both
so those were the past five
and you were right there was an element
of Randomness to them General Randomness
but I am I have no complaints you did a
great job you're doing great sweetie
thank you um but the show's not over
don't fret because finally the
long-awaited deer toaster segment is
coming up and it is brought to you by
Lululemon Lululemon shorts were made to
stretch flex and support the infinite
ways of working out giving you the
courage to LEAP into something totally
new and unexpected so they've got a ton
of shorts at Lululemon ones that are
really tickling my fancy specifically
the hottie hot short so they are short
with a comfortable range of motion and a
really flattering fit so the hottie hot
short allows you to Max your stride so
you can move freely with confidence
they're lightweight Swift fabric lets in
airflow so you can move without baggage
they also have the Wonder train short
which is the short with supportive
stretch that also keeps you dry they're
powered by an everluxe fabric which is
the Wonder train collection manages heat
and sweat so you stay comfortable and
focused so what's great about the Wonder
train short and a lot of the Lululemon
products is their sweat wicking and
quick drying material the breathable
everluxe fabric absorbs absorbs moisture
Wicks sweat during even the most intense
training also the stretch is really
supportive it's a streamlined design
that offers extra support so you can do
whatever you want to do without
interruption they also have men's shorts
that pace power the pace breaker short
it's a versatile short that is up to any
challenge if fabric is super lightweight
they are designed to Wick away moisture
and the Secure Storage means that you
can keep things close without feeling
that bounce so whether you're looking
for shorts for the summer for you know
any sort of athletic training or just to
wear around the summer when it gets
really hot and you're running errands
Lululemon is a brand that you can trust
the sweat wicking material like that is
real crotch sweat you know swamp ass
excuse my language is a real thing that
millions of Americans deal with and
Lululemon is tackling that one short at
a time so get into Lululemon shorts at
lululemon.com all right are you ready
for deer toasters I am dearest Jackson
turd thank you ladies for keeping me
company through quarantine new mom life
and Beyond I need some wisdom so I'll
get straight to it my husband and I have
been happily married for six years total
pjom we just welcomed our third child at
the end of last year that being said he
has started a new habit that makes me
want to murder him for the last several
months he has decided that he wants to
sleep with his hand on my ass and by on
my ass I mean bare ass skin to skin as
in he puts his hand in my pajama pants
he claims he quote likes to feel my skin
I find this so annoying I'm a
stay-at-home mom to three very young
children my oldest is only three and
someone is always touching me when I get
to bed at night I want to sleep in peace
I'm so annoyed I dream of moving to our
guest room so I can sleep alone other
than this we have a wonderful marriage
so please help me convince him that this
new habit is just annoying as [__] and
unacceptable sincerely a touched-out
toaster
interesting I'm actually I dealt with
something similar Ben does the most
annoying thing
and
I like I sleep on my side so like I
sleep on my left side and my right side
my hip kind of like my bone juts out a
little bit so skinny
and Ben like loves to rub it and it's so
weird to the touch and I beg him every
night he comes over he's like hip hip
I'm like I literally want to punch him
in the throat so what I started to do
um what I was go I would go over to him
and I would what would I think it was
like you know the really fleshy part of
your underarm like where like your like
bat wings I call them I would squeeze it
like really in the most annoying hard
way and be like and stop I'm like oh you
don't like that you don't like that hip
hip really showing them because to them
it's like innocuous it's like oh skin to
skin love but like when someone just
touches your skin in a way in a
sensitive area and in a way you don't
want to like they have to feel it in
order to understand why you're not being
crazy but you're valid
yeah I but I feel like what her
husband's doing like it is sweet you
should know it's not to pinch him in
return
um but could you guys find a compromise
where like he he wants skin to skin like
maybe hand holding or another touching
of the arm she doesn't want to be
touched she's a mom of three she's
touched all day people pulling on her
like she could she be could she get a
minute of Peace even in her Slumber yeah
do it back do it back
he would like it no but in a way that's
annoying
of course I wasn't caressing Ben's cheek
being like Oh my love I was being
[__] annoying pinching his underarm
and he stopped yep yep
okay
touch him back touch him back you gotta
get a dose of your own medicine
sometimes to like really see pity towns
like these are different medicines
it doesn't matter
so you're upping the dose
and you also know when somebody rubs
like a
lightly like caresses over the same
patch of skin multiple times it becomes
so irritating you can commit genocide
I'm someone who's like anti-touch so I
know what you're describing and I know
that
that it's not pleasant yeah but I also
you know intention versus impact
that's why telling him is not enough you
need to let him see firsthand yeah why
it's infuriating yeah no I could jump
out of my skin at the idea of someone
like continuing to rub the same area no
no it starts to feel like it's on fire I
can't I honestly am triggered now I'm
triggered so you touch him back that's
my advice
next up good luck dear Jackson Claude I
have a conundrum I work a job in a
manufacturing environment with pretty
strict no work from home policy I have a
rhinoplasty scheduled in November and
I'm busy saving up sick days to cover
the time the doctor says though it'll
take about two weeks before I can go
without bandages and I won't be able to
take that much time off do I just own it
and admit that I'm getting a nose job do
I pass it off as like fixing a breathing
problem do I say nothing the people I
work with are very nosy and very judgy
and essentially all men I don't want to
face the Judgment in a professional
setting when it's my face and my time
off to use help thanks a million that's
really hard
um if it's all men and they're judgy
like I typically with me like honesty's
best policy like you're getting a nose
job that's so exciting I would kind of
just lead with it oh yeah and take as
many 60 sick days as you can but
eventually like you have to do come in
with bandages so I would own it but not
if they're going to torture you yeah you
could say you were injured yeah I I also
think like I don't think there's any
shame in plastic surgery so I'm like
yeah own it who cares but if it's gonna
cause you like strong annoyance and
grief like it's just not worth it I know
it's your co-workers like it doesn't
matter if you're honest with them about
your plastic surgery that's so true like
you can say like over the over the
weekend like I ran into a wall or
something yeah like a screen door I was
just getting over being sick but I was
like a little foggy had some NyQuil but
like will they notice their men like
when you take off your bandage that your
nose is different no they won't no I
guess it's really we need more like
Intel on how drastic are you just like
getting a little bump fixed or do you
have like you know crater and you're
getting it like completely like maybe
like when you hit your nose on the wall
like it just it broke it corrected
itself yeah mentally would believe stuff
like yeah that's true I don't know if
they'd necessarily believe that your
nose looks different depending on how
drastic the surgery is yeah I think you
could tell a little lie you can but I
also think there's no shame in owning it
like I think these are two good options
like own it like literally who cares or
lie like you don't know your co-workers
full transparency you're just gonna make
your life easier yeah whatever's gonna
make your life easier go with that one
but they're both good options yeah and
it does you'll be okay regardless like
it's just annoying it is annoying but
two good options choose whichever one
you think will make your life easier
yeah but don't like feel bad about lying
like it's time people lie about like
sick days all the time like oh I'm sick
of you know there's Six Flags it's
whatever goes on in the surgery room is
between you and your medical care
provider like you're entitled to Medical
privacy you don't owe anyone like full
transparency on your plastic surgery no
but she comes in with Advantage like no
like you're gonna get questions you're
gonna get questions so we need to
navigate that yeah so I'm saying it's
okay to lie what's my point like I got a
surgery I agree
best of luck and I can't wait to see
your results I'm so excited for you
that's so exciting it is exciting yeah I
like I don't need a nose job but like if
I did I would get one like I think it's
probably so exciting yeah you know like
like you literally have a new face
also scary yeah potentially scary but
like for the most part fine yeah just
like new ice at Starbucks like it's
exciting it's exciting it's changed even
if it melts faster like it's exciting
the world is changing you know we gotta
get a lot of change with it yeah all
right our third and final to your
toasters dear Jackson Claude nope that's
one I just read oh dear tax include
Hyatt are different different she
obviously lives from the south my
boyfriend and I currently live
separately in a small Midwestern town he
pays 450 in rent but I pay about triple
that because she lives in like the city
and he's you know we're planning on
moving in together soon and I'm trying
to Mastermind how to divvy up the new
rent fairly it's about twenty two
hundred dollars obviously it's going to
be a huge rent increase for him too uh
split 50 50. I have a higher income than
he does and I work from home so I
understand that I should probably pay a
little bit more he could live in a tent
if he had to and is hopefully saving up
for a ring how do I go about splitting
our new rent what seems the most fair
and most importantly am I a Naggy [__]
girlfriend by asking him to pay more
just because I wanted a nice place love
a marketing turned Finance girl okay she
works in finance
so right now she pays he pays 450 and
she says she pays about triple let's say
twelve hundred dollars
so even if they both just continued
paying their rent it wouldn't add up how
much is the new rent 20 2200 so if she
paid 1200 and he paid 450 that's 16.50
they still have about 600 unaccounted
for I think they just split the
difference they each pay 300 more
oh that's a good solution even though
that is like his rent so much more than
him and that but that also is like
almost double his rent if he's paying
300 more that's true it's like unfair on
both sides yeah but is his rent low
because like he's been living alone and
he lives you know off in an area that's
in the beaten path less populated and
like he just has a low Runner like can
he not afford to pay more than that yeah
if he just is like living and also if he
can't really do more than 450 like maybe
I shouldn't be living in an apartment
that's that expensive unless you're
totally fine but she wants what she
wants so if you're totally fine paying
that if you have to pay for it if she
pays like the
pretty much 1800 and he pays 400. I mean
that's crazy yeah that's that's really I
think I would even be saying that if it
was like a man and a woman like that's
crazy
because at that point it's like well why
is a woman paying any rent right you
know right no it also depends like what
is your philosophy like are you a
traditional girl will this bother you in
your relationship right every time you
get into a fight are you gonna bring
this up right because that's not fair in
which case like you guys need to get
into a small apartment yeah
yeah I just feel like I'm sure you could
swing it and even if you would be like
and if this is where you want to live
then you'll find a way to make it work
but I just feel like it's always gonna
be like the undercurring in your
relationship like you pay I don't know
an eighth of the rent no I mean if they
split the difference she'd be paying a
thousand dollars more than him
in a 2200 apartment
it's a lot it's a lot
but like what are your philosophies like
will this bother you are you traditional
like you know all that stuff
or you don't care if you don't care then
get yourself the apartment she also
shouldn't have to sacrifice how she
wants to live because her boyfriend
doesn't want to pay more rent yeah
so I think we could do a few things
split the difference so basically like
750 and
15.50
go to a smaller place or a lesser
neighborhood just something cheaper
I think those are your options
yeah but it's possible that he won't
even want to split the difference
because that really is like doubling his
rent I know but like he's getting a new
place like right I'm sure he maybe has
roommates now like he you can't even
like you're gonna move to a nicer
apartment that your rent's not going to
change yeah I think splitting the
difference is okay if you're okay with
it and it won't bother you as like but
you really need to like ask yourself are
you okay with it is it always going to
bother you yeah yeah exactly because
either like then you'll find a different
place or like maybe he could pay more
and also you need to know like is he
just doesn't want to pay more like
doesn't believe in spending that much on
rent or can't afford it can't afford it
which is a whole different host of
like uh you'll act differently based on
all those answers right so God's BTO
finances are tough but you're also a
finance girly so I think you can make a
spreadsheet you know that's so true just
come out come at them with an Excel
spreadsheet and he'll be so confused
that you'll just win
yeah but what does she want like what is
she winning the nice apartment like she
wants it she's like you know she's a
certain standard of living yeah and she
shouldn't have to change that okay
so those were your toasters again if you
ever want to write in it's dear toasters
gmail.com we will of course keep all
your [__] Anonymous don't worry about
that and you know we're smart girls so
hit us up for advice and if you've
written in recently
and we've given you some advice whether
you took it or not we want to know
we do so write us an update and
hopefully we'll get one next week that's
our show that's our week hope everybody
had an amazing time with us this week I
know I did I did too I like I said this
week just flew by and we'll see you on
Monday next week is a holiday weekend
it's the beginning of Summer you guys so
we have shows Monday through Thursday
next week but then it's Memorial Day
weekend so we are gone Friday and Monday
you know us we love a bank holiday so I
hope everyone had a great day thank you
so much for listening to the testimony
Morning Show we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're all set
available podcast anywhere podcast can
be found so at Spotify iTunes digital
public video I already cashback all the
places
day love you bye bye